and then the author mentioned yeah these
three groups these three groups of
misguidance know may Allah have mercy
upon you that Islam his people regarding
the deviated regarding those who
deviated in attributes of Allah come
from these three
groups so the first of them is those who
rejected the narrations regarding the
attributes of Allah and have denounced
and beight their narrators so they are
more harmful to Islam and his people
than the
disbelievers they are the the negators
of Allah's names and attributes and the
and the second group who hold them to be
authentic meaning uh and accept them
however they falsely interpret them and
they are more harmful than the first
group because of their false
interpretations of
them for
[Music]
then the author I mentioned the third
group they are those who abstain from
these two opinions and they have and
what they have taken as they claim they
are they doing which is they claim that
they are freeing Allah from any Tye of
resemblance to his creation they are in
need liars and what has led them to do
this or to say this claim of theirs are
the two first opinions so they are even
more harmful than the first two groups
so they outwardly claim that they do not
negate Allah's names or attributes but
they don't affirm the meaning of Allah's
names and attributes they don't affirm
the mean of Allah's attributes like the
they accept some and they they negate
that means that they negate theat the
true meaning of theat of Allah subhanahu
waala because they end up saying that we
do not know their meaning meaning that
what does that mean mean that we don't
affirm these attributes meaning we don't
affirm these attributes meaning so what
do they do is they negate the apparent
meaning and
here said that actually this type of
group or this group the MU
they are the worst of the uh they have
the worst of the statements of those who
came from these devia groups
so here the statement of the author
which we look at in detail is very
important and that is that when he
mention that the innovators or the
innovation has is more harmful
uh than that which the disbelievers are
upon that which the
disbelievers uh bring meaning not that
is worse than kufur not that Innovation
is worse than kufur but that it is
harmful meaning the people can be
misguided by by this Innovation whereas
the kufur is clear kufur is clear
meaning Innovation is harmful upon the
Muslims because they may not realize
that it is uh it is something which is
innovated
so and this is exactly what has
mentioned not that uh Innovation is
worse than than b no but rather uh that
it is more is more harmful meaning that
it
is less likely to be detected by the
Muslims and so they end up falling into
B so it's harmful from that angle that
angle it is more harmful than disbelief
and that's why the scholars like other
than him they clarified the seriousness
and severity of Innovations
said Allah did not yeah bring about
those Scholars who will refute that
which the innovators are upon then the
will
become then their Dean will become is
more will become more uh corrupted than
the overpowering of the disbelievers or
enemies
then the author mentioned from the
necessary Sunnah is to remain silent
regarding that which there is no textual
evidence from Allah or his
messenger or that which the Muslims
agree upon it's generalization and
leaving of subjecting it to either
negation or affirmation just as if it is
not affirmed except by way of a
legislated text or it is not negated
except by a legislated
evidence and this is in summary the
methodology
of regarding their belief in Allah's
names and attributes
if proof comes from the book of Allah
the of the messeng regarding this
attribute then it is an obligation to
accept that
attribute or that there is a negation of
that attribute that you find in the
Quran Sunnah and it is obligatory
thereafter for us to negate
it and as for that which is not reported
not affirming the attribute nor negating
the attribute nothing reported regarding
it in the book and the
Sunnah such as those Al or those texts
that may come and they are General text
allegorical text not actually uh even
not actually that which is
established so what is the the their
position is upon two aspects two
so that uh if there's no text regarding
a particular attribute or name then they
no there's no negating it and nor any
text saying affirming it so what do they
do they don't actually affirm or negate
like the AL which are General like JM
body and other than that these are not
there's nothing mentioned about them
yes so those who the second position
have is that they actually ask the
person who brings this term that is
ambiguous they say what do you mean by
this if he mentions the a correct
meaning so if he mentions the correct
meaning in line with that is which is
known from the text then we accept that
meaning and if he brings a false meaning
that which is not in the text nor in the
found in the correct in the book and
theah we don't affirm and rather we
reject his false
interpretation like for example if find
they may say that Allah has not got a
body we say to them the word JM body is
not mentioned not not affirmed not
negated in the book and the
Sunnah not so
therefore we don't affirm nor do we
negate because not negated or affirmed
in the Quran Sunnah
but we say to him what do you mean by
your statement
body if he
says if he says now what I mean by body
is that Allah is not like the body of
creation we say n this is a correct
meaning this is a correct meaning mean
that we do not liken Allah to
[Music]
Creation if he says however that Allah
has not body mean he not got attributes
then we reject that from that person
after we question them what do you mean
by this ambiguous uh statements
then the author ended by saying we ask
Allah glorified be he to grant us
success in that which is pleasing to him
by way of speech action and intention
and that he grants us life upon that
path which is pleasing to him and causes
us to die upon it and to cause us to be
with his Prophet Muhammad sallu alhi
wasallam and the best of his creation
Muhammad Al Mustafa his family and his
companions may Allah be pleased with all
of them may he GA us with them in the
Abode of his
generosity indeed he is the all hearing
ever near with his knowledge and ever
responsive and lastly he said every that
we did not attribute to the one who had
collected it then it is agreed upon Al
bukari and Muslim collected it in their
said may Allah reward you for your
presence and your coming here to benefit
May
allaha accept that from all of
us to the for his striving and beginning
end in the book with the the explanation
clear explanation may Allah make it
place it on his scales of Good Deeds on
the day of judgment when no wealth no
any child can any benefit can give any
other benefit